THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR THURSDAY
JULY ELEVENTH TWENTY NINETEEN
IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER PLEASE
ADVISE AND AUDIO RECORDING
TODAY FOR SEATED IS BEING MADE
THERE'S ALSO BEEN TELEVISED A
MATTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM
CARILLO HERE FLORA GRAYSON
KAMLAGER-DOVE MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RIVAS WORKS HERE
WE HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE BEEN
SEVEN JIM THIS IS OUR MOTION
TO MOVE I MISS WORK SECOND
PERFECT MATHIS -- MATTER
CENTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
HI COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM
CARILLO I CARILLO FIVE
FLORA GRAYSON REYES TONIGHT
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF AYE MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS
MATHIS AYE PERKS OVER BY QUIRK
SILVA I REMOVED FROM THE SITE
RECESS WORKS FINE WICKS I
LAURA HI LAURA I
THE MOTION PASSES AND
THIS RULES WHEN THIS JERK